every time i hear Libertarian Party
presidential candidate Gary Johnson talk
I get the sense that on many issues he
can go about three talking points deep
right an initial general talking point a
slightly more specific one and then
maybe one fact that makes it sound like
he really knows what he's talking about
but on some issues not all that is
basically it for depth and that became
clear in what I can only describe to you
as a UH hair-raising Lee cringe-worthy
moment on MSNBC when he was asked what
about the Syrian city of Aleppo and he
hadn't heard of Aleppo if you're
watching I am warning you I would not
have children in the room here I would
not be eating anything at this time I
would definitely be sitting because the
look on his face when he is asked about
Aleppo it's bad let's take a look at a
bar what would you do if you were
elected about Aleppo about Aleppo and
what is Aleppo no Aleppo is in Syria
it's the it's the epicenter yeah refugee
crisis okay got it got it okay well with
regard to Syria yeah I do think that
it's a mess I think it the only way with
week that we deal with Syria is to join
hands with Russia to diplomatically
bring that at an end but when we've
aligned ourselves with when we've
supported the opposition of the Free
Syrian Army the Free Syrian Army is also
coupled with Jeff Islamists and then the
fact that we're also supporting the
Kurds and this is it's just it's just a
mess yeah and that this is the result of
regime change that we totaled year in
headlines right i mean he looks like he
just had some bad new york city food
cart chicken and it's starting to hit
the wrong way in its stomach or
something like that uh what's the
credibility of oh yeah of course well
here's here's my of course here's my
answer that answer after you say what's
Aleppo is not going to be particularly
credible and uh uh that then then he
goes to well I would just do an alliance
with Russia on this which by the way is
what Donald Trump suggested in many ways
to go after Isis and what President
Obama essentially has done at least
insofar as the coordination of
airstrikes I feel bad for Gary Johnson I
feel so bad that I think we need to take
a break so I can sort of regain my
composure and the phone lines are
already blowing up and we will take some
calls after the break